bien bédié a été élu ce vendredi à
bulletin secret et sans surprise
président du conseil général des
yvelines
l'élection intervient une semaine après
l'annoncé de la démission d'alain
schmitz l'ancien président ump du
conseil général alain schmitz avait
pourtant assuré quelques mois auparavant
qu'il souhaitait aller au bout de son
mandat en mars 2015 dans la vie
lorsqu'on fait partie d'une équipe il
faut savoir interchanger les places à
des moments donnés il y en a qui jouent
j'ai un peu comme au psg il y en a qui
jouent un peu plus devant d'autres qui
jouent un peu plus derrière et puis
voilà
pierre bédier avait déjà été président
du conseil général entre 2005 et 2009 il
avait dû quitter son siège après avoir
été condamné pour délit d'initié et
prise illégale d'intérêt cinq ans plus
tard il est réélu avec 26 voix pour neuf
voix pour le candidat de la gauche
andré sylvestre et de votes blancs et
nuls de conseillère générale était
absente et n'avait pas donné de pouvoir
christine boutin et fanny reverra à
l'issue du vote car bédié a fait un
discours très politique où il a défendu
l'utilité des conseils généraux il a
évoqué un effort de maîtrise de la
dépense publique et une ambition pour
mener à bien des missions de solidarité
et des actions en faveur de l'emploi
plus qu'un discours d'installation une
vraie feuille de route soumise aux élus
et ce qui m'a frappé c'est le mot
ambitions pour le département un moment
même où dans son discours de politique
générale le premier ministre a évoqué la
disparition des départements et je pense
que c'est au contraire quand c'est le
devenir département est aléatoire qu'il
faut être encore plus ambitieux au
service des yvelinois donc j'ai reçu le
message cinq sur cinq de pierre bédier
du côté de l'opposition cette passation
de pouvoir entre alain schmitz et pierre
bédier est qualifiée de révolution de
palais quelque chose qui ressemble
avantage révolution de palais qu'un
véritable exercice démocratique par les
mêmes de manoeuvre politicienne oui je
maintiens je pense qu'il ya eu des
pressions des manoeuvres politiciennes
pour en arriver là on est arrivé
aujourd'hui après une interruption de
quelques minutes la séance a repris
classiquement 33 points étaient inscrits
à l'ordre du jour